- Welcome to the Lifespan Podcast,
where we discuss the science of aging
and how to be healthier
at any stage of life.
Hi, I'm David Sinclair.
I'm a professor at Harvard Medical School
in the Department of Genetics,
and I'm co-director of
the Paul F. Glenn Center
for Biology of Aging Research.
This podcast is about
why we age, and efforts,
and things you can do in
your daily life to slow,
stop, and even reverse the aging process.
In the last episode, we
talked about the skin,
the largest organ in the body.
We talked about how to stay looking young
and feeling good about yourself.
But today we're talking about
perhaps the most important
organ in the body,
and that's the brain.
I'm joined today, and on all
episodes so far, at least,
by my-
- Wait, so far, at least?
- Yeah, well, we'll see
how you're doing today.
- Wait, do you know something
that I don't?
- No, just, I'm enjoying this.
It's going really well.
Matt and I have been together for years.
We wrote the book "Lifespan,"
and he's also my lovely
co-host of this podcast series.
- Hey.
- Welcome, Matthew.
- I'm really terrified now.
Like we're coming up on episode eight,
and I'm not going to
be here for season two.
- Well, we're going to do
a season two, no doubt.
And I would not do this
without you by my side.
- Ah, can, Rob, can we make
sure that that part of,
like that I will not do
this without you by my side,
we really want to make sure
that that gets broadcast.
- Though I've been
known to change my mind.
- [laughs] So so far in this series,
we've spoken about how
aging impacts our bodies.
And even though very clearly,
there's really actually no separation
between our bodies and our minds,
these are integrated systems,
but we've sort of up until this point,
not talked a lot or much
at all about the brain.
And the reason for this is
because nobody at all wants
to stay healthy in their body
if they're not also healthy in their mind.
- Absolutely.
And we live in a world where
modern medicine, as we call it,
has been very good at keeping
most parts of the body healthy,
the heart, so cardiovascular disease,
cholesterol drugs, heart drugs.
- Increasingly over the years,
we've gotten better and better and better.
- Right, we're living longer,
but we're not living better,
because the brain is still aging
and getting these diseases.
Alzheimer's and other types
of dementia are becoming more prevalent
because we're living
longer, but not whole body,
not holistically slowing
down the aging process.
- In fact, so currently,
about 6.2 million Americans
who are over the age of 65
are living with Alzheimer's.
That's just one of
several forms of dementia.
But because we're living longer,
that number could grow more
than twofold to 13.8 by 2060
if we don't come up with
some medical interventions
that can prevent or reverse
Alzheimer's disease.
- And there's very little,
there's a recent drug that was approved,
but it barely works.
It makes a minor difference.
So we have to make a breakthrough.
And what we're going
to talk about today is
a totally new approach
to treating dementia,
and that is boosting the body's defenses
against not just Alzheimer's,
but against aging itself.
And it's my belief in my labs,
evidence that if you reverse
the age of the human brain,
Alzheimer's and other diseases
of the brain will go away,
and you'll even get your
lost memories back again.
But also, it's not just
about Alzheimer is today.
We're talking about other
things that happen in the brain.
We're talking about molecular changes
that make cells forget
what type of cell they are.
So nerve cells become
more like skin cells.
And there's another process
that's important during
aging that we'll touch upon,
and particularly about its reversibility,
and that's loss of blood flow.
- And this is really important
because a lot of people,
if you just say Alzheimer's, dementia,
people think that's far away.
They're going to fix that
before I get to that point.
But all of us, virtually all of us
go through some amount
of cognitive decline
in our middle years.
And so this isn't just about preventing
these things that are way downstream.
This is about making our mental,
our intellectual lives better right now.
- Well, the biological clock
is ticking all the time.
We're not talking about a
female's biological clock.
If you've listened to previous episodes,
you know we're talking about what's called
the epigenetic or Horvath clock,
and this is ticking from conception.
So even when you're
20, 30, 40, and onward,
that clock is ticking away.
And what you do in your 20s and 30s
will impact how healthy you
are in your 70s, 80s, and 90s.
So it's never too early
to listen to this podcast
and do the kind of things
that we're talking about
to slow down that clock.
- Before we can get to that,
we got to thank our sponsors.
- Absolutely, because this podcast
goes out for free thanks to them.
So first up, Athletic Greens.
Athletic Greens is an
all-in-one daily greens drink
that supports better health
and peak performance.
It's developed from a
complex blend of 75 vitamins,
minerals, and whole food
sourced ingredients.
It's filled with adaptogens
for recovery, probiotics,
prebiotics, and digestive
enzymes for gut health.
There's also vitamin C and zinc
citrate for immune support.
I've been drinking Athletic Greens
for a number of years now
as a way to cover all
my nutritional bases.
I'm often traveling, and
sometimes my diet isn't the best.
So by drinking Athletic Greens,
I know I'm getting the
vitamins and minerals
that I need to stay healthy.
So if you'd like to try Athletic Greens,
you should go to
athleticgreens.com/sinclair,
and you can claim a special offer.
They're giving five free travel packs
plus a year supply of vitamin
D3 for immune support,
and vitamin K2, which keeps the calcium
out of your arteries and
puts it in your bones.
Again, go to athleticgreens.com/sinclair
to claim this special offer.
Today's podcast is also
brought to us by InsideTracker.
InsideTracker is a
personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data from your blood and DNA
to help you better understand
your body and reach your health goals.
I've been using InsideTracker
for over a decade,
and I'm the chair of their advisory board.
The reason I've long used InsideTracker is
because they provide the best blood
and DNA analysis that I'm aware of.
They make it easy to get your blood drawn.
You can either go to a clinic
or have someone come to your house
and have it done there like I do.
InsideTracker then presents
your blood analysis in an
easy way to understand.
There are graphs,
and then they give guide and
lifestyle recommendations
that'll improve your blood by a markers.
Another feature that InsideTracker has is
their inner age test,
which I helped develop.
The test shows you what
your biological age is,
how it compares to your chronological age,
and what you can do to improve it.
So if you'd like to try InsideTracker,
you can visit them at
insidetracker.com/sinclair
to get 25% off any of
their InsideTracker plans.
Use the code Sinclair, my
last name at the checkout.
Today's podcast is also
brought to us by Levels.
Levels is an app that syncs
with a continuous glucose
monitor that they provide.
And it interprets your
glucose data for you.
I've been so impressed using Levels
that I recently joined
the company as an advisor.
By monitoring your blood glucose levels,
the app allows you to see
what different foods do to impact you.
I've had lots of fun
running tests on my own
seeing how different foods
impact my blood sugar levels.
For example, I've learned
that white rice really
spikes my blood sugar,
whereas potatoes don't.
As we'll discuss on today's podcast,
having stable blood
glucose is very important,
not only for daily mental
and physical energy,
but also for long-term health.
If you would like to try Levels,
you can skip 150,000
people on a wait list,
and you can join today by
going to levels.link/sinclair.
That's levels.link/sinclair.
- Anyone who's been following along knows
that we have presented a case
over the last few episodes
that aging is largely a result
of X differentiation of cells.
Let's touch on that really quickly,
'cause that's going to
be an important point
drawing through this episode as well.
- You won't read a lot
of this in textbooks.
This is new science.
- You won't even read the
word X differentiation.
This is something we-
- That comes out of our work, yeah.
And this podcast, you heard it here first.
The idea, the new idea of aging is
that it's not just
random stuff going wrong.
Is that there's actually a
program that begins at birth.
What happens during birth
and prior to that is that
cells gain an identity.
We start as a stem cell that's fertilized,
and these cells different identities.
Brain cells, skin cells, liver cells,
everything that makes our body up,
the many thousands of different types,
tens of thousands actually are given
their cell type specificity
by turning on different
genes out of the same genome,
so almost-
- Through epigenetic signalers.
- It's called epigenetic.
The epigenome is the
regulator of the genome.
And the epigenome is not as
easy to describe as the genome.
The genome is just a
chemical with four letters,
four chemicals that is the instructions,
but then there's a computer that reads
that software called the epigenome.
Or we also use the analogy,
the reader of the compact disc,
that old device we used to
fit like 20 songs on it,
was really exciting.
But what we can now do
instead of 20 songs,
there's 20,000 genes,
but the reader is the epigenome.
And over time, by that analogy,
aging is due to scratches on the CD,
and you cannot read the right
songs at the right time.
And a brain cell over time
starts to play the music
of a liver cell or a skin cell
and doesn't function as well.
And we get diseases of aging,
including Alzheimer's as a result.
- In the last episode, we said that skin,
it appears that skin ages faster
than most other systems in our body.
And we can use these clocks also,
and have used these clocks to
measure aging in the brain.
And when we measure aging in the brain,
we find something really interesting.
- That the brain ages slower
than the rest of the body.
- Like significantly slower.
Your brain is biologic,
very good chance that your brain is
biologically younger than you are.
- Well, thank goodness,
'cause it's the most important organ.
Without a functioning brain,
we're really quite useless.
- So one of these studies was led,
actually a couple of these studies was led
by your friend and sometimes
collaborator Steve Horvath.
- All right, before I get
into Steve Horvath's work
on the cerebellum, important stuff,
let's talk about how that
clock is actually measured.
'Cause that'll be important later
for when we talk about diet.
Steve measures the methylation on the DNA.
It's a chemical called a methyl
that the cells add to the
DNA and it sticks there,
it doesn't wash away,
and it makes sure cells
have their identity
and play the right genes
for the rest of your life.
The problem is with aging, that changes,
and you can measure that.
In my lab, we can do
it for about a dollar.
And then the readout tells
you, okay, that brain,
even though the person is 40
years old, actually is 50.
- But you could look at the liver
and you could see that
the liver is actually 55,
and you could look at the skin and say,
oh, the liver's actually
62 in equivalent numbers.
Horvath and his associates looked
at tissue samples from 112-year-old woman.
And they measured the clock
in all these different parts of her body.
And the regions of the
brain were all much,
much less methylated
than her other organs.
So that was the first study.
And then they've done other
studies just a few years later.
They did a study that showed
across a lot of samples,
predicted age is lower in the brain
than really anywhere else in the body.
Sometimes like a quarter of the age
of other parts of the body.
- Well, there's a practical
and an evolutionary explanation for those.
The practical one is that
our brain is protected.
There's a blood-brain barrier.
It doesn't get hit by UV
light like our skin does.
- We have these big thick skulls.
- We're basically lollipops on a stick.
But our brain needs to be protected
from these toxins that
are in the environment,
and of course anything
that leads to brain aging.
But of course, our brains will still age.
DNA breaks, we've talked about.
Broken chromosomes accelerate that clock.
And this happens naturally even
to cells that don't divide,
including neurons, the
nerve cells in our brain.
- One thing to note is
that a cellular turnover is
relatively low in the brain.
So even though these cells,
even if they're not
dividing, they still do age.
That process of slow cellular turnover
could explain some of the reasons
why the brain doesn't X differentiate
as fast as other regions in the body.
- Yeah, that's probably right.
Unlike the liver, you can cut
a piece out, it grows back,
the brain doesn't easily do that.
There's a little
neurogenesis, as we call it,
but mostly those nerve cells are
going to there for your whole life.
And so they have these
super protective mechanisms,
these adversity systems
that keep the brain younger for longer,
but they're not perfect, of course.
We do have an aging brain,
but there are ways to
turn on those defenses
greater than they naturally
would be activated.
- And so all of this is the good news.
The good news is, in general,
our brains age more slowly
than the rest of our bodies.
The bad news, as we said at
the beginning of the show,
is that we are living longer.
That's actually good news too,
but it's got a bad news component
because our bodies are now outliving,
in some cases, our brain.
The average onset of
dementia is 80 years old.
And in most advanced nations now,
the average lifespan is
more than 80 years old.
And so what that really means is
that more and more of us
are living with dementia
at the ends of our lives and
other cognitive impairments.
That's a terrible fate.
That's something that we should
all be working to prevent.
- Well, that's why I work on aging
and not Alzheimer's disease
or cancer, specifically.
As we've said in earlier episodes,
by working on aging, we can
keep the whole body young,
including the brain, which
is really what we want to do
if we want to have maximal
gains in longevity and health
and mental capacity right up to the end.
- And again, there's not,
because you work on the whole body,
you're not working on the whole
body when people become old.
We're talking about the whole body
across the span of a human life.
And there are advantages to that too,
because everybody suffers
some cognitive decline.
This is a little terrifying.
The volume of the brain
after the age of 40 reduces
about 5% per decade.
And that's got cognitive implications
for all of us as we enter
what's used to be called our middle years.
- Well, yeah, I'm 52.
I can already feel it happening,
but I'm doing certain
things in my lifestyle.
We're going to tell people
about some of those things
you can do to slow that process down
and even reverse it later in life.
- So a lot of people
might think, well, okay,
it does make a lot of evolutionary sense
that the brain starts to
have struggles at 30, 40, 50,
but for one thing, for a
long period of our history,
people didn't actually
last that long in general.
- Right, most males
would die from predation
or war or starvation in their 40s and 50s.
Some people did make it to their 80s.
But for most of our history,
we didn't need our brains as
an 80-year-old, same for women.
- Well, and we didn't need
a really super sophisticated
executive functioning
to survive even when we
were in our 30s and 50s,
well, 30s, 40s, and 50s.
If you made it that far,
your life was going to
be pretty much the same
on Monday as it was on Sunday.
And it was going to be pretty
much the same on Sunday
as it was two Sundays before
and two months before
and two years before,
and even like 200 years before.
- Right, as we talked
about in the last episode,
getting gray, losing your hair was
signs of wisdom and you got respect.
And presumably, you didn't
need to be that quick witted.
You had a lot of wisdom
and experience that would compensate.
But we live in a world
now where every year,
you have to be learning something new,
and jobs are turning over.
And it all started in the 1700s.
Now we find ourselves at the point
where it's really difficult,
even for young people, to
keep up with this change.
- And this is what we call
a plastic environment,
an ever changing environment.
And that has implications
in terms of how our brains develop,
and the plasticity that we need
to respond to these changes over time.
- Yeah, I watched my
grandmother, who passed away,
and we wrote about in "Lifespan."
She was a mentor to me.
Actually the reason
that I do this research.
She told me to make the
world a better place.
So she has a very dear spot in my heart.
What I saw happen to her
as she got older was she just shut down.
She didn't care about life,
but she also didn't care about change.
And so she didn't worry about computers.
She didn't bother
learning how to use that.
She didn't bother learning
how to play a compact disc.
And the last 20 years of
her life weren't that great.
Nowadays,
you cannot be an older
person and ignore technology,
or you'll be isolated.
You can't talk to your grandkids.
This COVID-19 and the pandemic.
- Yeah, imagine what,
and this did happen to a lot of people,
but this is a really terrible thing.
If you were not able or willing
to adopt new changes to your environment,
you were not going to be
able to talk to people
during the shutdowns, during the pandemic.
- Yeah, I was just at
the Apple store getting
a new phone just a couple of days ago.
And I was there, there
was a lot of young people,
but then in Cayman, an older person,
she was probably 85, the way she looked,
and the way she wasn't walking that well.
But she went up, and
I reckon 20 years ago,
it would be rare to see someone
in a computer shop of that age.
Now she went up and said,
"Hey, I know about the
new operating system.
I need to get a new iPhone.
And by the way, my iPad
needs an update as well."
I was shocked, and I
remembered my grandma-
- Can I link this to my smart walker?
- Yeah, exactly.
And I find also in our generation,
so you're on your 40s, I'm in my 50s,
we cannot slow down either.
We can't say, all right,
I'm just going to deal
with my compact disc or record collection.
We have to be, use Spotify
to talk to our kids,
we share files, social media.
If you need dates, you
need to figure out that.
Jobs, the job market's changing totally.
We used to have one or
two jobs in our lives.
Now we might have three
jobs, we're mobile,
we work remotely, and it's
turning over all the time.
That requires a brain that
is highly, highly adaptable.
- And so what we want to talk about now is
this idea of keeping our brains
and bodies aging at about the same rate
so that we don't suffer physical decline,
and we don't suffer cognitive
decline through the,
as much of the entirety of
our lifespan as possible.
And that's really,
as we've had all of these advances
in keeping our bodies
younger and healthier,
it's really about keeping the brain
younger and healthier too.
That comes down to some of the same things
that we've been talking about
throughout this podcast,
these three longevity pathways.
- Yeah, so those who've
been with us will know
that there are three main
buckets of longevity factors
that respond to adversity.
And these have evolved
to sense the environment
when times are tough.
We call them adversity mimetics
that turn on these three things.
So the buckets are mTOR,
which respond to low
amounts of amino acids,
particularly leucine, isoleucine, valine.
There's the AMPK pathway.
AMPK senses low energy,
low glucose levels,
and makes more energy, more
mitochondria, boost NAD.
And that's important for the third group,
which are the sirtuins that require NAD
and can be activated by certain chemicals.
Importantly, they all work together.
We'll talk about later that
sirtuins can activate AMPK.
AMPK can activate sirtuins and mTOR.
What they do downstream is complicated.
We're not going to get into that
except relevant to the brain,
but they protect the body.
They turn up metabolism, they burn fat,
they repair DNA, they
clear out senescent cells,
they lower inflammation
among many other things.
- Can we dive a little into mTOR?
We're going to talk mostly about sirtuins,
but there's a real key role
that mTOR plays in autophagy.
- Well it does.
They all play a role in autophagy,
but mTOR is the most potent one.
mTOR responds to insulin
signaling and fasting.
And in response,
it mobilizes proteins to be recycled
and made into new proteins
when you're hungry.
And that's called autophagy,
the garbage collection
and trash recycling system of the cell.
And that's particularly
important for the brain.
'Cause as we get older,
there are these misfolded proteins.
In the eye, they're called lipofuscin,
and then in Alzheimer's,
they're plaques and tangles of proteins.
And to get rid of those, you
need really deep cleansing.
It's called chaperone-mediated autophagy.
And mTOR is a really
great way, not activating,
but downregulating mTOR,
turns on those recycling
pathways really effectively.
We're not going to talk
so much about that,
though we are going to talk a little bit
about changing our diet to ensure
that all three of these
pathways are working
in the way that will promote brain health.
- And even though we're really
mostly going to be focusing
today on the sirtuin pathways,
you could be assured
that the lifestyle advice
that comes along with this,
it works for all three of these pathways.
- It does, 'cause they're
talking to each other.
The reason we're going to
focus on the sirtuins is
in part 'cause I've been
working on them in my lab,
but also because they become
central to brain health.
And so we'll cover both.
And also what's important
about the sirtuins
as opposed to these other two buckets is
that the sirtuins respond to whole variety
of environmental pseudo-stresses.
We call them adversity mimetics.
We're going to talk about food,
talk about exercise and
supplements that you can take
that should activate these three
pathways quite effectively.
And we think based on
animal studies as well,
and human studies, should
slow down brain aging
and even potentially reverse it.
- And there's several types of sirtuins,
but one in particular,
there's a couple that are
important to brain aging.
One in particular is called SIRT1.
- Right, so there are seven
of these genes in every cell in our body.
The brain makes a lot of SIRT6 and SIRT1.
And over time, the levels
of both go down with aging,
as well as the fuel that
those enzymes need called NAD.
But we'll focus on SIRT1 mostly
because that's what seems to be
the most important for
controlling brain aging.
- Let's talk about the role of sirtuins
when it comes to aging in the brain.
- Well, remember this
clock is ticking away
because the loops and the bundles
of the DNA are getting messed up.
The bundles become loops, the
loops are becoming bundles.
We've linked the sirtuins to that process.
What happens when a cell
is overstressed, overbroke,
and overdamaged is that
the sirtuins have two jobs.
They have to create these bundles of DNA
and make sure the cell has its identity,
so the genes are read
like a proper compact disc
or a software in a computer.
But when chromosomes
break or you crush a cell,
there's a panic attack.
And the sirtuins rush away to help
with that stress and
repair the broken DNA.
But then they have to find
their way back to where they came from
and reestablish that
structure of the epigenome.
And they do a pretty good job.
99.9% of all of those structures
go back to how they were.
But that .1% never goes back,
and over time accumulates.
And these are the
scratches that cause aging.
- And in order to mitigate that,
what we want to do is
upregulate the sirtuins.
And we can do that through NAD boosters.
- Right, well, in the mouse in 2008,
we published that just
upregulating SIRT1 gene
in the nerve cells of a mouse's brain
were sufficient to slow aging and prevent
those loops and bundles from changing.
And that was the first evidence
you could slow down a mouse's brain age.
But you can't modify our
brains genetically just yet,
so we need to find safe ways
you could take a chemical,
a pill hopefully, rather
than an injection,
that will increase SIRT1's activity.
The ones we know of are
resveratrol and NAD boosters.
We'll talk about those in a second.
And then they give the benefit
of a good diet and exercise.
And in combination, even better.
- Well, let's talk about
those things first.
Let's talk about diet and exercise,
'cause that's got to be the foundation
on which we build all this other stuff.
- Well, absolutely.
We've talked previously
about the Mediterranean diet.
And one of the reasons
is that it's very clear
in over a dozen studies that
a Mediterranean-type diet
protects the brain from aging,
and can even reverse aspects of aging
in the elderly with mild
cognitive impairments.
- Yeah, there's a study earlier this year
from a really large
international research group.
It was led by Tommaso Boldrini.
It showed higher adherence
to a healthy diet,
in this case, the Mediterranean diet,
is associated with less amyloid beta,
less tau, larger gray matter volume.
If some of these words
are sounding familiar,
it's because they're all associated
with Alzheimer's disease.
- And there was a second study
that I found fascinating.
This one was by Anastasio et al., 2017.
And it was over 1,000,
actually close to 2000 people.
And there was a 10%
reduction in dementia risk
for people on the Mediterranean diet.
And-
- There's actually a 10% risk reduction
for each Mediterranean diet score,
which means the more
Mediterranean your diet,
the better you were doing.
- Right, and so that includes
olive oil in the diet,
red wine, and not a lot of red meat.
- Yeah, and not surprisingly,
this is a research team from Greece.
They really like the Mediterranean diet
for obvious reasons.
- Yeah, what I want to get into later,
and hopefully we will is,
what is it in that diet chemically
that can help the brain?
- Well, I don't know that we need
to wait too long to get into that.
Let's talk about that.
What is it in that diet chemically
that can help the brain?
- Well, there are a number of things.
I would put them into a
few different buckets.
There are vitamin that can be deficient,
that we need to talk
about the clock later.
But first up, there's red
wine, which has polyphenols.
Resveratrol is one of those.
And my lab has been working
on resveratrol for many years.
And that directly activates SIRT1.
It makes the enzyme, it's like Pac-Man,
and it's controlling
genes and it works faster.
So resveratrol from red wine
has clearly been shown to be beneficial,
and also prevents cancer
and not just has metabolic
and brain-enhancing effects.
The other component of Mediterranean diet
that works on SIRT1 is olive oil.
And [indistinct] recently showed
that if you add oleic acid,
which is a major component of olive oil,
it's also found in avocados
and other good foods like that,
can also directly activate the enzyme
by sticking to it and making this Pac-Man,
I don't know if everyone
knows what a Pac-Man is,
this little puppet creature
on an electronic game,
chomp faster.
And there's probably other molecules.
We talked previously in another episode
about xenohormetic molecules.
Plants make these molecules
to survive stress,
and when we eat them,
we get the benefits of that
stress, because we worry,
our bodies worry that our
food supply might run out.
- One of the, and that's sort
of the overarching nature
of a plant-based diet,
whether it's Mediterranean
diet or some other diet,
is that it is mimicking adversity.
Your body's got to work a little harder
to get everything that it needs,
that's sending the signals that
maybe times aren't so great
and we need to activate
these longevity pathways.
- Well, that's the difference
between a Mediterranean diet,
and a high fat carnivorous diet,
and a typical Western diet.
They're full with calories,
full with a whole bunch of stuff
that tells the body times are good.
It's a bounty.
No need to protect ourselves.
Let's just burn the candle at both ends
and forget about life later.
And that's not what you want.
What you want to do is to have
the perception of adversity.
And the Mediterranean
diet, as well as in Japan,
what's called the Okinawan diet,
which has low levels of
protein and mostly plant-based,
those two trick the body into thinking
that the food supply sucks
and could run out any minute.
- And these diets aren't perfect, right?
Let's talk about some of the things
that you need to make sure
that you're getting enough of
if you are eating this plant-based diet.
- Right, well, one of the
first things to worry about
if you're just focusing on plants only is
a deficiency in folic acid.
This is vitamin B12.
Low-
- This is the supplementation
that they give to pregnant women,
'cause they're often low in folic acid.
- Yeah, and there's a good reason why,
which I'll get to in a second.
There are other B vitamins
that are also important
to make sure that you have enough of,
vitamin B6 and B3.
We've talked about B3 as early component
that's building up that
NAD for the sirtuins.
So B vitamins, especially if
you're on a plant-based diet,
but for everybody, don't
be deficient in these.
Why?
Because the B vitamins are the ones
that make sure you have the methyls
that are added and
subtracted from the DNA,
that controls the DNA methylation clock.
If you have low levels of B12,
it's known that you have deficiency
in the ability to methylate DNA,
and that will mess up your epigenome,
and very likely accelerate the clock
in a way that causes aging.
And there are a lot of
studies that have shown
that deficiencies in B12
accelerate a variety of diseases,
heart disease is the major one,
but also dementia in the brain.
And the main reason I
think what's going on is
that aging is being accelerated
when you don't have enough
of these B vitamins.
- And the result of low B vitamins is
an elevated level of homocysteines.
- Well, that's a markers, yeah, exactly.
So often your doctor,
but not all the time,
measures homocysteine levels
because it's been shown to go up
as a predictor of heart
disease and dementia.
And high levels are
particularly dangerous.
Most doctors would want you to have less
than 10 micromoles per liter.
Some people go as high as 100.
If you're that high,
you're certainly going to die
in the next few years of
cardiovascular events.
So you try to keep the
homocysteine levels down.
And the best way to do that is
to make sure B12 levels are optimal,
not too high, 'cause that
can also cause problems.
Again, you have to measure it.
I use InsideTracker to
measure my B vitamins.
But also you want to
avoid too much alcohol,
definitely don't smoke.
Your menopause will also affect
your homocysteine levels.
Certain types of cancer will.
And aging itself leads to
increases in homocysteine.
- And this all materializes as plaque.
- Well it does, but homocysteine itself,
I don't think is the problem.
It's that the methylation pattern
on the DNA is getting messed up.
The sirtuins can't cope.
SIRT1's not good at going
back to where it came from.
And your body will get older.
And when your body is older,
it has more inflammation,
can't get rid of plaque,
builds up calcium in the arteries
instead of being in your bones,
and that we call diseases,
but that's actually aging going on.
- I think a lot of people think
about elevated homocysteines
in terms of what's going on
in their blood vessels
throughout their body.
But we're having a conversation
here about our brains.
It's important there as
well, maybe even more so.
- Well, yeah, it's known that
high homocysteine levels,
which is a version of an amino acid,
do correlate with increased
susceptibility to dementia.
And the reason probably is
that we have vasculature in our brain,
and that these are very small vessels
that are needed to bring
oxygen and take away toxins,
and they clog up really quickly.
And with high homocysteine
levels as an indicator,
we're getting plaque also building up.
And not only that, the endothelial cells
that are like the lining
of the blood vessels,
they literally are,
but they need to remain
flexible, like rubber bands,
they become defective, they
age, and they become stiff.
And then they start to
accumulate this cholesterol,
and then you get occlusions.
And that can ultimately end in a stroke.
But even before that,
those occlusions are limiting
the amount of oxygen your brain gets,
leading to of course losing your ability
to remember things, even at my age,
but ultimately what's
called vascular dementia.
- There's a pretty simple way
to monitor that accumulation.
- Yeah, you just look in your eye.
Well, you don't look in your eye.
- It's really it hard.
I actually tried earlier.
- Yeah, a doctor, an ophthalmologist,
or even an optician will look in there
and have a look at the back
of the eye, the retina,
and they can see very clearly.
And they'll take photographs.
They can show you of whether you've got
a perfect blood vessel lining,
these blood vessels sit
on top of the nerves,
which is a bad design, but
that's how we are designed.
They will see those blood vessels.
And if they're occluded, that's
a really, really bad sign.
We've actually known for many decades
that if you see one of these
occlusions and a lot of plaque,
you basically are going to suffer
from a heart attack and die pretty soon.
- Yeah, you have like a,
it's like a 15% chance
of death within a year.
And then it goes up from
there in really scary measure.
- Exactly.
In 1959, Dr. Robert Hollenhorst
found that these plaques,
these little occlusions that he could see
in the back of the eye with
his lens predicted survival.
It got really bad, in
fact, what's now known,
if you see these, you got a 50-50 chance
of being alive seven years later,
and that's really scary.
- That's really scary.
So obviously, staying ahead of this,
not letting that accumulate
at all is preferential,
even to catching it early.
- Right, and think of this.
Your eyes are a window into your brain.
In fact, your eyes are your brain.
They're extensions of those
nerves with balls at the end-
- I know, that's creepy.
You told me that before,
and I got creeped out.
- Yeah, when you look
at someone in the eye,
you're actually looking at their brain.
Pretty cool.
But what's great about is
you can see into your brain.
And that's what we're
talking about here is
getting an indicator
of how much occlusion,
plaque there is building
up inside your skull.
- Let's talk also about fatty acids
and the importance of really making sure
that you're getting the right
and the right kinds of fatty acids.
Particularly if you are
on a plant-based diet
and you're concerned about brain health,
which we all should be.
- Right, even with a normal diet,
you often don't get enough of
these omega three fatty acids,
which are the types that
we don't make ourselves.
If you're only meat
and you don't eat fish,
you eat animals besides fish,
you're not getting a lot of them.
And they're the building
blocks of the brain,
so we need a lot of them.
And they've been shown
in a number of studies
to help with many different things,
from wound healing, and
of course, depression.
Now, what are the sources?
Well, if you eat fish, you're
probably in good shape.
You've got salmon and
mackerel, krill, sardines.
These are good sources of omega-3s.
- And these are giving
us the DHAs and the EPAs.
'Cause there's three different
kinds of these, right?
- Well, there are lots,
but the three main ones
that people talk about are EPA and DHA.
The EPA is the more important one.
You want to get at least a gram of that.
Sometimes people say,
get 1.6 grams of this ratio of EPA to DHA,
and women about 1.3 grams.
And that's been shown
to greatly improve memory
and counteract depression.
Now, if you're a plant-based person,
you can't obviously get as much,
you have to focus on other types of food
that have what's called
alpha-linolenic acid or ALA,
which is converted
slowly, not efficiently.
About 10% of it gets converted by the body
into the two types we just
mentioned that are important,
the DHA, and importantly, the EPA.
Focus then on flaxseed,
walnuts, chia seeds.
That's where you get your ALA.
Linseed oil is where it
was first discovered,
ALA, linolenic acid.
I use that to polish certain things,
keep wood looking good, cricket
bats, you put it on there.
But you can also, you
can consume a little bit.
There's a lot of it in there as well.
And there's one other
thing I want to mention
that isn't in that list of three,
which is a monounsaturated
fatty acid called oleic acid,
which is really important.
And I mentioned it earlier.
It's a component of
olive oil and avocados.
And I have that included in
my supplement every night,
along with these other components.
- As a recent convert to seaweed salads,
I would be remiss not to note
that you can actually get,
it's one of the few plant sources
you can get DHA and EPA
from is from seaweed.
- Is that right?
- It is right.
- Well, I don't know if
you get enough of it.
I think it's really a
good thing to consider.
And talk to your doctor about it,
to take at least a gram
of these omega-3 fatty acids every day.
- So we know we should be
consuming these omega-3s, but why?
What are they doing on ourselves?
- So it turns out these
omega-3s actually form
a structural component of the brain.
They insert along with
other fats in the brain.
So fat is actually good for the brain.
A lot of our brain is
made up of these fats.
The reason is that the
nerves aren't naked.
Much like an electrical wire,
you don't have them lying
around your house naked.
They're actually wrapped
with insulation tape
or insulating material.
And that's what these fats do.
And these are membranes that wrap around,
it's called the myelin sheath.
And these fats, actually,
some of them are omega-3s.
And the more omega-3s
you have in your diet,
the more you'll have in those membranes.
And that protects from
inflammation and damage,
and helps the nerves function
and repair if they get damaged.
- We have to eat for brain
health because what we eat,
what we consume helps make up
the parts of our brain that
keep our brain healthy.
We also have to exercise for brain health.
We can't neglect that part.
And we can't think that exercise
just affects us from
here down, it doesn't.
- Well, that's actually
known in dozens of studies.
It's been shown that if you do
aerobic exercise or even just walk,
that'll improve your chances of having
a better memory and
cognition as you get older.
The reason we think that is,
is that there's two reasons.
One is better blood flow,
and also better neuronal activity
and slowing aging of those cells.
That involves the sirtuins,
this third protective survival pathway.
That can be activated, of course,
by the food, and also by exercise.
- We've seen this in a number
of both human and animal studies.
- Well, that's right.
There are a number of studies
that we could talk about.
The one that stood out
for me in our research was
the one that involved 160
sedentary, sitting down,
non-exercising adults that
were told for six months
to do extra aerobic exercise,
to do some aerobic exercise.
- Yeah, they were actually,
they were led through this process,
'cause you can't just tell
humans to do anything.
They're just not going to do it.
- They had a cattle prod
and they're pushed onto a treadmill.
Something like that?
- I don't think it's
that highly regulated,
but they do make sure they
actually do the exercises.
- So Blumenthal and his colleagues
found, what was it, 2019,
that this greatly improved
executive function.
- Executive function.
- Yeah.
- That's the function that's like co-equal
to the judicial and legislative function?
- It's kind of like that, but
kind of different, which is,
so you know a lot of kids
don't have executive function.
They can't focus.
They can't do tasks right.
That's what executive function is.
Concentration, focus, do some tasks.
- And so just a little bit of exercise,
six months of exercise
improved for these people,
they're all over the age of 55,
improved dramatically their
ability to do these things.
- Well, they did.
And I think that that's one
of the main reasons for exercising.
You might want to do it not to
just because you feel better,
but you will think better too.
- It's hard to take people
who have Alzheimer's, Parkinson's disease,
other cognitive problems
through things like that,
because it's just, at a certain point,
you lose the ability to
get them to respond to you.
But there's also lots of
evidence in mice for this.
There's a study this year
out of Brazil that showed
that exercise had a
really significant effect
on mouse models of
Alzheimer's and Parkinson's.
- Right, so it's not just
aging that exercise works on.
What you're saying,
and what's in the literature
is that diseases of aging,
and also including Parkinson's,
which is age-related,
are benefited as well.
There's another study.
It doesn't have to
include aerobic exercise.
There's one where there's
strength exercise.
So if you don't like running,
pick up some weights,
because what's been found
in this study, this is 2013,
Perera and colleagues found
that in an elderly cohort,
they had 451 people,
just 10 weeks of strength
training increased the level
of factors that grow new
brain cells, new nerves.
This marker is called BDNF,
or brain-derived neurotrophic factor.
And we use that as a way of indicating
the youthfulness of the brain
and regrowth of new nerve cells.
- And the takeaway here is
that at a time in many people's lives
when they're becoming less active,
it's actually more
important than ever before
to become more active and to stay active.
- Before it's too late.
It's very hard to get a
very elderly grandparent
or parent to get on a
treadmill or lift weights.
So what we want to do for ourselves
and for our parents and grandparents is
to get them moving early
on before it's too late.
- Even if we're eating well,
even if we're exercising,
presumably, our ancestors
did these things too.
If they hadn't, we wouldn't be here.
They faced these sorts of adversities
all throughout their lives.
And that's what we're trying to mimic
through our diets and our exercise.
It still might not be enough,
because we do live these
lives of incredible comfort,
and we eat a lot of food.
And so we might need a
little additional help
when it comes to keeping
our brains healthy.
This is where supplementation comes in.
And one of the supplements we
want to talk about is metformin.
A lot of people are going to say,
oh wait, that's an AMPK activator.
You guys said you were talking about SIRT.
But we're actually kind
of talking about both.
- Well, yeah,
there's crosstalk between
these various defenses.
The AMPK pathway talks to
the NAD sirtuin pathway.
When you take metformin,
and you get this mitochondrial
hormesis, mitohormesis,
that will raise NAD levels.
It'll stimulate the production
of the enzyme that turns NMN,
a precursor of NAD, into NAD
itself and raise NAD levels,
and get the sirtuins active
as well in the brain.
- Okay, and we know that metformin is good
for brain health from
a variety of studies.
One we want to start with
today is this fish study,
which I did not know
that they did cognitive studies on fish.
- Fish are actually used
quite often in labs.
And most of them live about
two years, as long as a mouse,
which doesn't make them
that much more advantageous,
but there are short-lived fish.
There's one called Nothobranchius furzeri
that lives only a few months.
There's one, in this study,
they used redtail notho,
which is guentheri,
Nothobranchius guentheri,
and it comes from Zambia.
It lives a bit longer.
Its environment isn't as
harsh as the other one.
And over that year, what it
does is it breeds very quickly.
It lays eggs that become
encased in a shell.
The fish then dies,
and those eggs will survive
until the rains come again.
But it's a great model for aging,
because it goes through its
lifecycle super quickly,
but it's built of the same
stuff that mice and we are.
- And how do you tell that a fish is
having cognitive impairment
or cognitive success?
- So it sounds crazy
measuring memory in a fish,
but they do have good memories.
You can test it in a variety of ways.
You can put food and a light,
and see if they remember
that the light is where the food is.
They come to the light if
they have a good memory.
You can put them through
mazes, like a mouse,
they swim through if
they've got a good memory,
and they know where the
food is at the other end.
And the third one is where you
test their fear conditioning.
It's reaction and memory of fear.
And you shine a red light in the tank,
and then you get a stir
like you would a cocktail,
and swizzle it around, and they,
sure, if they remember that,
next time they see the light,
they should run away, or
swim away, I should say.
And so what they did was,
in this study was they found
that by treating these
fish with metformin,
put a little bit of
metformin in their food,
those fish were able to remember
those tasks much better as they got older.
- And so the Ted lasso quote
about being a goldfish and
immediately forgetting things,
that's not true?
- No, fish have a really
good memory actually,
and they have brains that
are quite similar to mammals.
- So when you give these
fish the metformin,
what's happening cellularly?
- Molecularly, what's happening is
that the metformin molecule gets
inside the cell and into the mitochondria
where there's what's called
the electron transport chain.
This is a series of bundles
of proteins, five in all,
that pass electrons between
them like a hot potato,
and generate chemical energy.
Metformin disrupts that first step,
and in doing so releases free radicals.
Superoxide anion is one that goes off
and damages parts of the cell.
And we call this damage mitohormesis,
which is a little bit of damage
makes actually the cells stronger.
One of the main things that happens is
that the cells react and say,
oh my goodness, we don't
have enough energy,
make more mitochondria,
more battery packs,
more energy for the body.
That's always a good thing with aging
and health and longevity.
The other thing that happens
is that this signal sends
a protein called GLUT4 to
the outside of the cell
in the membrane to suck more
sugar out of the blood stream,
and having lower blood
sugar protects the body
from this caramelization process
that also causes many diseases,
including dementia, by
clogging up the arteries.
- High blood sugar is not
good for brain activity.
- No, it's not good for any tissue.
What happens is this glucose
that's in your bloodstream,
if it gets too high,
it actually binds to proteins, about 10%,
five to 10% can be covered
in this glucose molecule.
That's bad for their function.
It's often hard to remove,
and it leads to dysfunction
particularly of the cardiovascular system.
- We're not just seeing improvement
in cognitive function
with metformin and fish.
There's been studies on mice.
There's been studies on rats.
There's been studies on humans.
- Yeah, there's a bunch.
Our researchers did a great job,
and they're all fairly
recent, 2014 to 2019.
The one that I want to bring up is
Koenig and colleagues in 2017,
a really good study.
It's randomized,
placebo-controlled crossover.
That's what you always look for.
Metformin improved, again,
this executive functioning,
the ability to focus,
by treating 20 non-diabetic
normal subjects.
And they had mild dementia
when they started,
and they improved,
which means that dementia is
somewhat reversible with this drug.
It also means that if you're starting
to lose focus in your
job, daily activities,
either taking Metformin may help,
or just keeping your glucose level steady,
which is what a lot of us do,
and we measure that daily
with monitors on our arms.
That is also a way to stay focused.
- And that's a small, really
well controlled study.
There's also a really big,
less well controlled study,
but nonetheless really
impressive study from 2019.
It took a really huge
cohort of diabetic patients,
tens of thousands of them.
Dementia incidence for the
metformin users, 55% lower.
- So actually, it was preventing
the onset of dementia by what, 55%?
- Right.
- That's a massive number.
When we talk about these numbers,
often it's a five to
10% decrease in disease.
55% is a massive number
that we should definitely
pay attention to.
- There's been some
suggestion that metformin,
in addition to acting on AMPK,
and then the chain of
custody moves its way down
and AMPK acts upon NAD,
metformin actually might
impact NAD directly as well.
- Yeah, so that study
was super interesting
from a few years ago that metformin
could directly interact
with, bind to the enzyme,
and make that Muppet, that
Pac-Man creature go faster,
in the same way that
resveratrol has been shown to.
But that was only done in one study.
And of course, in all science,
we need to reproduce it,
and we're still waiting on those results.
In my lab, we've tried it.
We haven't had perfect results
yet, but we're still trying.
- In the meantime,
there are more direct
ways to impact NAD levels.
And that's through NAD boosters.
There's been lots of
animal research on this.
It elevates cognitive functioning.
It promotes recovery after
brain injury, all good stuff.
- Yeah, why would you
want to supplement NAD
in the first place?
Well, it's known,
just like the rest of the
body that in the brain,
NAD levels go down for a
couple of main reasons.
One is that we don't make
as much that NAMPT enzyme
that's activated by
metformin and exercise,
goes down, so you don't make as much.
But also it was shown by Jeffrey Milbrandt
at Washington University in a
couple of high profile papers
just in the last few years
that there's an enzyme
that gets turned on in nerve cells
when they're damaged called SARM1.
And it depletes the cell rapidly of NAD.
So what you've got is a decrease
in the production of NAD,
also with an increase in
the degradation of NAD.
So supplementation we think is important,
to not just get the youthful levels back,
but go beyond that, to mimic exercise,
mimicking a perfect diet,
especially for the elderly
who cannot always do those things.
- And we've got a long
history now of research
going back almost 20 years
of NAD supplementation on brain health.
There was a study in 2004
that showed treatment with
NADH slowed Alzheimer's.
And a lot of people hear about NAD+.
NADH might be a little unfamiliar.
- NADH is basically NAD
with a hydrogen atom attached to it.
NAD+ has a positive charge
like the end of a battery.
And then if you stick the hydrogen
onto the vitamin B3 part of the NAD,
then that's going to be called NADH.
And that's important in a cell,
'cause that's the other
major function of NAD.
One is to turn on the sirtuins
and DNA repair and all that good stuff.
But it also is known as a
hydrogen carrier molecule
that takes hydrogens and moves
it from one place to another.
- So why would NADH work if
NAD+ is what's the standard?
- Well, what I think is
going on here is that,
so NAD activates sirtuins in
a test tube and in the cell.
NADH actually has the opposite effect,
so you don't want high levels.
So what's probably happening is
that NADH gets into the bloodstream,
gets degraded into its various components,
vitamin B3, there's a phosphate,
there's a part of DNA called
a nucleotide, the A letter,
and they get reassembled back into NAD+.
You're just giving the components
in a concentrated form by taking NADH.
- Another more recent
result, a combination of NR,
which is another kind of NAD booster
that we talked about a few episodes back,
and pterostilbene slowed
down the progression of ALS.
- So NR is different from NMN.
Let's go through that again.
When you want to make NAD,
what the cell does is it takes vitamin B3,
or niacin, or nicotinamide,
turns it into NR.
So the nicotinamide gets
now a sugar, ribose.
And then to make NMN, it puts a phosphate,
which is phosphorus and oxygen.
And then it combines that
together to form NAD.
So those are the various steps.
Now, what NR is, it's a
couple of steps back from NAD.
And so when you take NR,
it's made into NMN, made into NAD.
But it's been shown in
humans by taking large doses,
about a gram of NR, you'll make NMN,
and you'll make higher levels of NAD,
which is shown to be important
in this study in ALS patients.
Those ALS patients
actually benefited greatly
from this supplementation.
The other component I forgot
to mention is pterostilbene.
And the pterostilbene
part of it is resveratrol.
It's resveratrol with three
methyl chemicals on it.
It's essentially a way of delivering
in a pill form resveratrol
plus an NAD booster.
- This was a pretty short-term study.
It showed immediate
returns for ALS patients
when they took this combination
of NR and pterostilbene.
But Lenny Guarente,
who's running the study
out of his lab at MIT,
your former mentor there,
we chatted with him this morning.
He said, actually,
they're now looking at a year long study
so that they can see if
these results continue on
for a longer term for
patients who are dealing
with a really, really
debilitating disease.
- For which there is no cure,
or even effective treatment.
So this would be a big deal.
And most of these trials fail
in the first stage, phase one.
They're in phase two, so they
made it further than most,
but of course, it's a very
difficult disease, ALS,
Stephen Hawking, it's just a
terrible, debilitating disease,
very hard to treat, but
fingers crossed for this one.
Hopefully those patients
will continue to do better.
- Can we talk a little bit
about this idea of increasing blood flow,
and what NAD boosters do for blood flow?
One of the studies that
you were involved in
showed vascular improvements in mice
that were put on these boosters.
But vascular flow isn't just
important in our bodies.
It's, well, frankly,
it's more important in our brains, right?
- Right, we forget about our brain
needing blood flow and oxygenation,
'cause we don't really see it.
It's not part of our daily thoughts.
But it's just as important,
if not more important
than the rest of the body.
We found not only does
NMN and SIRT1 activity
maintain the youthfulness and ability
to grow new blood vessels
in the mouse as muscle,
but we collaborated with Zoltan Ungvari
at the University of
Oklahoma to show that mice,
even in their brains,
benefit from NMN by
building new blood vessels.
And those elderly mice not
just had better blood flow,
but could think and
remember things better.
- And we think
that's because of the
improvement in vascular tissue.
- Well, almost undoubtedly,
that's what was going on in those mice,
because we could block the effect.
We could actually downregulate
the SIRT1 specifically
in those endothelial cells
that line blood vessels,
and then the benefit of NMN went away.
- And this turns mice with older brains
into mice with younger brains?
- That's essentially what happens
when mice and people get
their ability to learn again,
that's reversing an aspect of aging.
- So before we move off of the topic
of sirtuins in the brain,
it's not just blood vessel
that are being affected.
It's not just the cerebellum.
There are other parts of the brain
that are also really
well impacted by SIRT.
- There are a few things I
want to mention about SIRT1
before we leave this topic.
One is that overexpression,
turning up SIRT1 in all of the nerve cells
in the brain extends a mouse's lifespan
and protects them against these diseases
that we induce in them,
ALS, Huntington's, and
Alzheimer's disease.
The other thing is,
there are a couple of
regions that are of note.
One is the hippocampus,
which secretes hormones
into the bloodstream,
and that can actually
reduce blood glucose levels
by talking to the liver.
The other area of the
brain is the hippocampus.
This is the part of the brain
that consolidates memory.
And it was found in old mice,
if we activated that part of
the brain with resveratrol,
or activated SIRT1 by
putting in more copies
of that gene and turning it on,
those mice had better
memory even in old age.
So really what this
says is that SIRT1 plays
an amazingly important
role in delaying aging,
preventing diseases of aging in a mouse,
and potentially even in a human.
We'll see how those trials continue.
But let's talk a little bit about sleep,
'cause the hypothalamus
controls the circadian rhythm,
day and night rhythms of the body.
- Yeah, let's talk about sleep,
because quite frankly, if you don't sleep,
you're in a lot of trouble.
And you're going to age faster.
There's lots of research on this.
- Yeah, even at the molecular level,
we understand that SIRT1 and NAD play
a fundamental role in controlling
your wake-sleep cycle.
SIRT1 and NAD are going up in the morning,
coming down later in the day,
getting your body ready
for sleep, and in doing so,
what they do is they turn on
a particular gene called BMAL,
which is part of the clock,
not the Horvath clock,
but the daily clock,
the circadian rhythm clock.
And those genes tell
the liver to calm down,
it tells the brain to calm down,
and in the morning, tells
everything to wake up again.
And so what is really
important to understand is
if you start to lose the function
of SIRT1 and have low NAD levels,
you're probably not going to sleep well,
but also, you're going to age prematurely.
- And the big problem here is
that sleep efficiency
actually declines with age.
So we got to work harder
at sleep as we get older,
just like we have to
work harder at exercise
as we get older to promote brain health.
- Yeah, another way of saying
it is that as you get older,
you lose your ability to sleep.
And if you don't sleep well,
you'll lose your ability to fight aging.
And it's just a feed forward disaster.
So you've got to intervene.
You can intervene
with the kind of things
we talk about here,
which is eating well, exercising,
and intervening with the kind of things
that you can take perhaps as a supplement.
But now, let's talk about what do we do
to make sure we sleep well,
and we have the right rhythm.
And one of the key
things that I use is NMN.
NMN is going to raise NAD
levels in the morning.
I take a gram of it then.
But I also, when I travel,
I use it to reset my body.
And I definitely feel that I
can avoid jet lag if I do that.
- There's some other supplements
that a lot of people take.
Magnesium?
- That's good for sleep.
L-theanine is another one that people try.
I've used it, seems to help me.
But essentially, you just
want to calm down at night.
Don't do your emails too late.
Relax your brain.
- And then I think a
little counterintuitive,
one of the best things that you
can do for sleep at night is
actually not something you
do before you go to sleep.
It's something you do right
away when you wake up.
- You mean go outside?
Get some light?
- Well, you got to get light.
You got to reset your circadian rhythms.
And the best way to do
that is put yourself
in a situation where your
body knows it's daytime.
- Well, you can.
But here in Boston where I live,
there's not a lot of light in winter.
So I actually have some blue light
that I can shine in my eyes
to get my cortisol levels up,
synthetic way, not naturally.
But whatever you do,
try to get some light
early in the morning,
'cause that always gives
you an energy boost
and helps you reset your circadian rhythms
if they're not perfectly in sync.
- And like the other things
we've talked about today,
there's lots and lots of research.
We're not just making this up.
Sleep is important, we know this.
- Well, yeah, even in flies.
Flies sleep.
It's a little known fact.
But before we get to the humans,
I want to, this is a really cute study.
It was a study that was
in 2020 in fruit flies.
They found that if you
deprive flies from sleep,
they have a lot of oxidative
stress in their gut,
and they also have a short
lifespan, which by the way,
could be rescued by treating
them with an NAD booster.
- Which is also a way that we've seen
that you can rescue human
subjects from sleep deprivation.
But even just one night
of sleep deprivation,
a lot of people say, oh, you
know, I'll catch up tomorrow.
I'll catch up the next day, whatever.
Maybe I didn't sleep well tonight,
but I can sleep well the rest of the week.
One night of sleep deprivation increases
amyloid beta production by 5%.
That's, you don't want to
miss with amyloid beta, right?
- No, that will accumulate in your brain.
It's very hard to get rid of.
And I was also shocked to read
that it's not just the brain
that ages if you don't sleep.
We already know that if you
restrict rats from sleep,
they get diabetes within two weeks.
In humans, looking at a million people,
this study's from 2010, Capucho et al.
What they found was
that in people that had very little sleep,
the risk of dying was 30% higher
than those that got a
natural, normal night's sleep.
- And the thing is,
our brains are getting so
much adversity right now.
We talk about a little bit
of adversity being good,
but we evolved to have a pretty low,
constant low level of adversity
popping up now and then.
And right now in terms of the insults
and injuries that we're taking
in in terms of stresses,
daily stresses, everything changing,
our brains are being
besieged all the time,
we need sleep to reset.
- It's just too much.
There's too much to remember.
There's too much to cope
with, too much anxiety.
We just are living through a pandemic.
This is really stressful times.
And just lack of sleep makes it worse.
And physically, we will
regret it decades later.
- The overall message today is
we got to keep our brains healthy.
And we have to work to
keep our brains healthy.
We can't just expect
that they're going to do
what they've always done
throughout our evolutionary history,
which is to last longer than we have.
We've figured out many of the tricks
that are going to keep us
alive for longer holistically,
but we got to keep our brains healthy
for at least one day longer
than the rest of us last.
- It's super important that
we look after our brains.
It's not just about ourselves.
It's about our families.
Many families have had to take care
of parents and grandparents
that have dementia.
This is not pleasant for anybody.
And we have a responsibility to society,
and particularly our family members,
to stay healthy for longer,
particularly keeping our
brains younger for longer.
- In our next episode,
we're going to be talking
about a lot of the things
that we sort of hinted at
throughout the series so far
in terms of what's coming next.
Maybe what's coming next in a few years,
maybe what's coming next in 10 years.
And what if we can keep ourselves
from aging too quickly over
the next couple of decades,
might be a quarter century away
and sort of waiting for us
there if we get there healthy.
- Well, it's a super exciting time.
The reason we're doing this podcast now is
to bring the audience,
the world along with us,
and to experience these changes
essentially in real time
as they're being made.
And the kind of results
that are in the lab
and increasingly going
to customers, consumers,
and eventually to patients
in hospitals and at home
with medicines will be directed
towards lengthening lifespan,
not just by one or two
years, but by decades.
And I can see that coming.
We're going to talk about
some of these things
that'll include wearables, monitors,
and even age reversal technologies
that get that Horvath DNA
methylation clock to go back,
not just a couple of years,
but potentially by decades.
- One of the things that I noticed,
and we've talked about
this a lot, you and I,
many of the things that we
talked about in the book,
that we said, these are a
little ways down the line.
It's only been three years since the book,
two years since the book was published,
and a lot of those things
are coming to fruition
a lot faster than we had even thought.
And so these things that
maybe in the next episode,
we're going to say, ah, these
are kind of far down the line,
who knows, they could
be here next Tuesday.
- Right, it's blowing my mind
how quickly things are changing.
I didn't realize the discovery
of reprogramming in the eye,
which was in the book, and
we published very recently,
has taken the world by storm.
There's billions of dollars
being poured into this.
So it's very hard to predict
how this is going to look
just a few years from now.
Plus the wearables, these
things are changing,
and coming to the public all the time.
The other thing that's happened
thanks to the pandemic is
that home remedies and
home testing has taken off.
So there are things we can now do at home
that were beyond even the imagination
when we wrote the book.
- Yes, fundamentally changing
what healthcare is going to look like
in this next part of the 21st century.
- Well, it's exciting.
A lot of our health
and our wellness is in our own hands now.
we have the tools,
we'll have the knowledge to
greatly lengthen our lifespan,
of those of our parents, our
grandparents, and our kids.
And that's in part what
we're going to talk about
in the next episode of "Lifespan."
If you're enjoying this podcast
and would like to support us,
please subscribe on YouTube,
Apple Podcasts, and Spotify.
On Apple, you have the opportunity
to leave us up to a five-star review.
Also check out the sponsors
that we mentioned at the
start of the episode.
That's probably the best
way to support the show.
These sponsors not only make it possible
for us to get this show to you at no cost,
but they offer products and services
that we truly believe in,
and we think that you'll really enjoy.
We also have a Patreon account.
It's at patreon.com/davidsinclair.
And there, you can support this show
at any level that you'd like.
Thank you again for joining us
on this episode of the "Lifespan Podcast."